oh man um yeah yeah yeah hey what is
going on with you [ __ ] always paying
your bills late even though there's
automatic payment you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you know as I mentioned before I'm
only going to do videos when I want to
there's no set schedule now if you guys
have been on Twitter or the internet in
general or if you're a [ __ ] human
being uh-huh you guys know that Anthony
Bourdain passed away now when I found
out that Anthony Bourdain passed away
what could have happened was it a car
accident did he get mugged
that I don't know did he go like
swimming out in the ocean to go hunt a
shark and then he became bait but the
reason for his passing has been
confirmed is suicide now instead of
talking so much about the topic of his
death I I do want to talk about how
important how much this guy meant to me
and I never met Anthony Bourdain if I
did meet him trust me he would have it
would I would have bought my ha when I
found out that Anthony Bourdain passed
away man I gotta tell you something like
I didn't I did not expect to cry you
know I legit started to bawl and I
didn't know why you know I never met the
man I didn't have a personal I guess
connection with them aside from the
content that he created it really got me
to think because you know I never
understood like how people could be so
affected by you know youtubers few years
back when I was living in k-town um yeah
I went to this like concert thing that I
was like a part of or or award I was
invited out to and there was like a
k-pop star that he was a part of this
group called poon bang Shinji or
something like that
DBSK this dude when he walked out I saw
this girl and there's like this
escalator on the left right escalator
Escalade oh [ __ ] escalator anyways as
the girl was going up the escalator she
noticed that her Idol was walking by and
about to go onstage and this is what
that little [ __ ] look like
Oh what the [ __ ] is going on from the
bottom of the escalator all the way to
the top
she cried non-stop and in my mind I'm
like [ __ ] what what happened to you
what and the reason why I bring that up
is just to say like I didn't get like
how the [ __ ] could you you've never met
the guy you don't [ __ ] know the dude
how can you be so affected and when
ethany Bourdain passed away I understood
it I cried over a man I didn't know I
cried over a man who I saw on TV who
obviou maybe he has terrible sides to
him maybe he has a dark past but
whatever he presented to me or whatever
he taught me through the art that he
created affected me deep guys want to
know like how much Anthony Bourdain
affected my life just look at that
Taiwan series that I did a couple of
years ago every Bourdain was somebody
that that taught me so much about myself
now growing up in Sacramento California
you know that that place was a small
town and when I was there and even when
I was like pursuing to become a stand-up
comedian and go into entertainment I
couldn't really see outside of this
small bubble that I was living in you
know aside from wanting to do comedy and
music or whatever the only other goal
that I really had that I was pushing for
was probably just to get married have
kids and live in this house with the
white picket fence and that's really
about it that was as far as my
aspirations what because in my mind I
just live in this small bubble and not
only because that bubble did I have
small goals for myself my view and
perspective on human beings and people
were also very very [ __ ] small bitter
on I don't remember when but I started
to watch and follow Anthony Bourdain and
maybe not just him but he was one of the
bigger people in my life or like the one
of the major catalysts that got me to
think like y'all David like you what the
[ __ ] are you doing my perspective on
life was this big this little small
little hole that you see in my fist
that's like the [ __ ] lens that I
would see everything with watching
Anthony Bourdain to mind you yeah he was
a chef and when he did have a show he
was talking a lot about the food but it
was beyond the food it was the culture
and I started to realize something about
myself I didn't know [ __ ] everything
that I thought was so big major and huge
in life wasn't really that
and I kind of learned that through
watching him just experience and learn
from other cultures when you have a
small mind and all you care about are
the opinions of this small group of
people around you you tend to be a very
hateful person why because you're
ignorant you don't understand other
cultures and then you start to like
press what you believe on to other
people because your world is so small
and there's only set rules within that
world and that was the person that I was
and that was the person that I was
becoming and when I watch this man I
started to I guess you could say I've
idolized him because he opened up my
eyes and he kind of taught me how stupid
I am I wanted to be that man I wanted to
be somebody who was open-minded but who
was a strong enough person to still
carry his own opinion and that's not an
easy thing to do and that's who Anthony
Bourdain was he was unapologetically
himself when people heard of the story
of Anthony Bourdain passing away or
committing suicide people couldn't
really understand it you know and I
heard a lot of life
I wouldn't say insensitive but very
misguided forms of thought you know
particularly one thing they maybe kind
of like nudge me in a very bad way was
people would people kept saying this I
don't understand how you could be so
unhappy when you're that successful see
when somebody says that when they go
you're successful you have everything
what do you have to be unhappy for well
the thing about that is like depression
has nothing to do with that depression
has nothing to do with how successful
you are all the things that are around
you so depression has something to do
with not being able to understand
comprehend and appreciate the things
that you have to no fault of your own
you just you just for some reason it
doesn't connect and I get so sad and I
think about this and I'm not sure if
this is like the right way to think
about it but I kind of wish in my mind I
was like man
if he could only see the value in
himself that everybody saw him and that
guy like teaches me so much things that
no no necessarily if it's his purpose in
life but even with his passing like he
only reaffirmed what I'm doing you know
it's not about views it's not about
people who know you it's about creating
a body of work and a legacy where you
can live on forever and hopefully like
I'm doing that you know hopefully I'm
doing that with the films the TV stuff
that I'm trying to write and then the
businesses that I'm opening up
I hope I'm hoping I'm creating a legacy
for people to remember me by not as a
guy who you know went around throwing
pies in people's face and not as the guy
just doing anything of [ __ ]
everything on a tag or a post to get any
type of you or any modicum of Fame
someone who is a a mover of like
cultures you know again gets people to
think and I want to be that so bad
success is not a form of happiness
people and the definition of happiness
by the way it's not something that's
objective happiness is very subjective
my whole life I keep searching for this
thing to be I guess like content and
happy at where I'm going to be or where
I'm at you know and what I mean by that
previous statement is that if if we look
at other people's success and you say
that if I reach that level of success in
your eyes but then I'll be happy then
you're really never going to reach that
because in my personal opinion like what
what does like society telling you what
success is affect how you feel about
yourself that's something that's very
fleeting because you're basing your
emotions off of what somebody else is
telling you how to feel do you
understand what I'm saying cuz you
really have to think about it people
like what will what really is success is
is money and indicator of success as
money an indicator of happiness and I
don't really think that it is because if
that was the case then I guess my
parents are super [ __ ] unhappy right
because we didn't grow up with a lot of
money I mean to us or to my parents
success was having two kids that were
able to grow up in a country with food
in their stomach a house over their
[ __ ] head they went to college they
had an education for me somewhat if you
ever feel like you want to take your own
life take the step back and breathe for
a second you know a lot of the stuff
that we feel is temporary you know what
it means like I feel like emotions are
like Twitter you know what I'm saying
like people people are in there feeling
at the very moment and if you can't like
crawl out of this dark hole don't be
afraid to reach out and ask for help
there's a lot of ways to get out of this
depression and funk and you know a lot
of people have told me is like David
what you were going through was
depression it's like I guess maybe it's
just I don't want to label myself as
that not because it's like a negative or
bad thing it's because I I have a
support group I have people around me
that are helping me out of this
quote-unquote depression you know I
reach out my head I'm like yo please
help me out in the Kabat and they pull
me out of that dark space and I I have
that and I want you guys to have that
too if you don't find value in yourself
but you don't find value in your life
I'm telling you that there's value there
that you have to push through it and
that's everything in life there's always
discomfort you know there's always gonna
be a part of your life where you're
gonna hate yourself there's always gonna
be a part in your life where you feel
like you've dug yourself such a deep
hole that you can't get out of it but I
guarantee you if you persevere it'll
always get better at the more Dane you
will be missed
I wish I could have told you how much I
appreciated you in person but then you
know opportunity obviously is not going
to come true anymore so rest in peace
man
[Music]
you